Hey everybody its Charlie this is going to be my video for the ending of fantastic beasts to crimes of Grindelwald
They made some huge changes or additions. I should say to Harry Potter Canon
So I'll try to explain what they did and how they're misleading you a little bit
I think they're not giving us the whole  story if you're new to the channel
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos and obviously careful for spoilers if you have not seen the movie
Yep, we have to talk about a couple really big plot twists
So here we go at the end of the movie Ezra Miller's character credence is with Grindelwald
Grindelwald tells him his true identity
and that's the huge change introducing a brand new character that has a lot of big longtime Harry Potter fans scratching their heads about how
It could possibly exist
So during the movie Grindelwald makes this big deal about how credence is so important to him because he's the only person who can defeat
Dumbledore and Dumbledore is the last thing standing between him and taking over the world in the way
He tells that story is really important too. He says oh I am certain
He's the only person that can defeat
Dumbledore like he's been sitting on a really big secret this whole time that goes all the way back to the original Harry Potter films
When we learned about Dumbledore's past he tells credence that his true name is Aurelius Dumbledore
And he's Dumbledore's long-lost, brother
Then tells him the same story about the Phoenix the Dumbledore told earlier in the film about how his grandfather
Told him a story about how a Phoenix would always come to a Dumbledore in need
So it's a marker of their family birthright and evidence that he's not lying about him being a Dumbledore part of their family
But Grindelwald is slippery
He'll say anything that he wants twist the truth omit things about the story in order to get credence to his side
So I think he's only telling a half-truth. He is related to Dumbledore, but he's not his brother
So this will make more sense
When you think about the origin story for the Dumbledore family that you learned during the original Harry Potter story?
But just to clarify the reason why Grindelwald needs Credence so badly isn't so much that he's related to Dumbledore
It's because of the obscurest the obscurus is what makes Credence so powerful
Any idea how dangerous it is? You're a distraught?
Dumbledore's brother
You know what to do
Where did you sent her?
you'll see soon enough
That's your sister Ariana, isn't it
She died very young didn't she
My brother sacrificed many things. Mr. Bardo on his journey to find power including Ariana
And she was devoted to him
He gave her everything
Good time
Thank You, mr. Dumbledore, so getting into the idea of Credence and where he fits into the Dumbledore family tree
Here's the problem. We know from Harry Potter Canon
The Dumbledore had one brother Aberforth who he met during the series and a sister Ariana Dumbledore
There were only three of them and they're relatively close to the same age
Dumbledore himself in this movie is about 30 years older than Credence
So it's just way too old for him to be his natural born brother
Dumbledore's father actually went to Azkaban after an incident with his sister when she was six years old
So he wasn't even around to have another child with his mother
We know though the Grindelwald spent a lot of time in Godric's Hollow with Dumbledore when they were young before Ariana died
So Grindelwald would have known ariana and everything that was going on with their family because he was so close with Dumbledore
There was the whole subplot about the Blood Pact
so remember that
Grindelwald and Dumbledore were like really close allies friends more than friends as he says and they were supposed to be the two most powerful
wizards of the age
Dumbledore tells a story during the film when he's talking to Leta Lestrange about his greatest regret was not
Loving his sister enough during the original Harry Potter films
Harry Potter learns the Dumbledore blames himself for his sister's death because of his selfishness
Quick recap about what happened to Ariana Dumbledore because I think she's very important to this story
When she was six years old
She was taken advantage of by a couple local muggles while living in Godric's Hollow in her rage to get revenge
She hoped out on them with her magic unable to control it
She's a little girl remember she sort of loses her mind and the Dumbledore's hide her away from the world for the rest of her
Life think about that story though the way she hooks out loses control of her magic
It sounds a lot like Credence in his obscurus so early theory when she was attacked by those boys she developed an
Obscurus just like him and that's the reason why the Dumbledore's hid her away because it was so dangerous
And so powerful they didn't want to turn her over because they were afraid that she would be thrown in Azkaban
And she was just a little girl and they wanted to protect her later when Dumbledore was getting ready to finish school
He was supposed to be the next Merlin the greatest wizard in the history of the world
So he had this bright future ahead of him
But he was also supposed to become his sister's guardian some time around then
Grindelwald came back to Godric's Hollow to work with Dumbledore and compel him to leave with Grindelwald
So that the two of them could be together and go pursue greatness
Because Grindelwald was also supposed to be one of the greatest wizards of the age. So he was like, come on
Let's go be great together were the most powerful wizards in the world
we can do anything that we want the books state that his sister died trying to stop a three-way battle between
Dumbledore his brother and Grindelwald over whether or not
Dumbledore would leave with Grindelwald to pursue that glory
so after she died soon after he took the job at
Hogwarts and swore off his pursuit of power because of his great regret like he just blamed himself for everything that happened to her
So big theory about the true origin of Credence
I think the credence is actually Dumbledore's sister's son making him Dumbledore's nephew
He inherited Ariana's obscurus
We also got the flash back to the boat where Leta Lestrange swaps her brother with Credence in that crib
We see the woman who was caring for Credence
We don't know who she was
But she could have been someone working for the Dumbledore's trying to take Ariana's son Credence to America to keep him safe
but I think the big twist here, especially highlighted by the fact that the Phoenix appears is that Credence is
Dumbledore's blood but not necessarily his brother. There was also this really creepy subplot with Leta lestranges father
He would use the Imperius curse on women that he wanted to have children with
Once he got the son that he wanted he cast all the women aside. So very creepy
But thematically the idea that Ariana had a tragic child under mysterious circumstances that sort of fits with that
But just to be clear if you haven't read all the Harry Potter novels
There is no mention of Dumbledore having another brother in the books it just the three of them
They're vastly older than Credence. So it just it makes sense that secretly he's going to be Ariana's son
The big question though is is that if Dumbledore knew that his sister had a son then why doesn't he know about Credence?
Maybe he also thinks that the baby died when the boat sank
but either way
I just feel like it's gonna be a big revelation in one of the future movies like they're related but not
Exactly how you think so let me know in the comments
Do you think the Grindelwald is lying to credence and he's really the son of Ariana Dumbledore?
Dumbledore's sister
If you guys didn't know - there's a Wizarding World
TV series that I believe Warner Brothers is developing for their new streaming service. That will debut sometime next year
I don't know if the Harry Potter TV show will debut next year maybe 2020
But the streaming service will debut next year if we get any more info about that
I will totally do a video what you wait for everything click here for my
Non-spoilery breakdown of all the early aquaman reviews and click here for my brand-new Game of Thrones season 8 trailer
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight